drugs come in different sizes from small
simple molecules like aspirin to giant
complex biological drugs like monoclonal
antibodies in recent years biological
drugs or biologics have revolutionized
treatments for cancers metabolic
diseases and inflammatory disorders in
2016 roughly a quarter of all global
drug sales were biologics but there's a
problem
these drugs are incredibly difficult and
time-consuming to make so they're often
prohibitively expensive that may be
about to change the patents on many
biologics will soon expire which means
that competitors can try to make cheaper
copycat versions called biosimilars
making a generic version of a small
molecule drug isn't too difficult
chemists can reverse engineer the
structure and use familiar synthesis
techniques to create an exact copy
but biologics are much more challenging
making an exact copy is impossible
because of their size and complexity and
the original manufacturers have no
incentive to share their assembly plant
so the biosimilar developers have to
start from scratch first developers need
to reproduce the basic structure as best
they can
based on careful analysis of batches of
products and published data then they
need to replicate the three-dimensional
drug with functional parts this is such
a complex process that scientists rely
on cultures of living cells to assemble
the drug for them by ceding control to
this black box system of living cells
the exact synthesis pathway remains
hidden and is impossible to fully
control another issue is that small
differences in these live cultures like
temperature pH nutrients and so on can
cause chemical modifications which can
affect the biologics function and safety
so the team must experiment to find the
right conditions to make the drug in
their own lab once it's been made the
new drug must undergo stringent tests to
check that its chemistry and function
are similar to the originates drug for
example it needs to undergo functional
tests to make sure it binds to its
target then the new drug needs to be
compared to the originator drug
clinical trials to make sure it works as
well as its predecessor and doesn't set
off an immune reaction or have any other
unexpected effects in the body
no virus similar will ever be identical
to the originated drug but modest
chemical differences are acceptable if
the drug passes these rigorous tests and
clinical trials this whole process can
take more than ten years but it's an
effort worth making if it means that
some blockbuster biologic drugs become
more affordable and accessible for
patients in the coming years
some say that biosimilars could reduce
global healthcare spending by a hundred
and sixty billion dollars over the next
five years